c'est la fin de l'émission votre
questionnaire votre mot préféré jean luc
godard à la
chouc schmouth ados
shox mouche oxmoze ça veut dire quoi
un mari
le mot que vous détestez
ministre de l'intérieur votre drogue
favorite
leur romanesque le son le bruit que vous
aimez
la pluie sur d'ordre dans les arbres et
le son le bruit que vous détestez
les couinements du fax
autres joueront gros mot blasphème
favori
excusez-moi matin j'en ai aucun
suisse ne jure pas
un mot femme pour illustrer un nouveau
billet de banque
adolf hitler
métier que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
ministre de l'intérieur
laplante l'arbre où l'animal dans lequel
vous aimeriez être réincarné
cauchemar
est enfin si dieu existe on y revient si
dieu existe qu aimeriez vous après votre
mort l'entendre vous dire à vous jean
luc godard
c'est pas trop tôt mettez-vous là
[Musique]